FATEMEH SHAMS TOOKT PART IN THE ANTI
GOVERNMENT PROTEST OF 2009
BEFORE I WENT TO FLEE IRAN FOR
THE UNITED STATES.
SHE NOW TEACHES PERSIAN
LITERATURE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA.
SHE IS FOLLOWING THE CURRENT
PROTESTS CLOSELY ON SOCIAL
MEDIA.
SHE SAYS THE MOVEMENT IS
ALREADY CHANGING POLITICS IN
IRAN.
--
WELCOME TO THE PROGRAM.
>> THANK YOU, FOR HAVING ME.
>> RESPOND TO THAT ONE STUDENT
WHO SAID, WE ARE NOT THE
PREVIOUS GENERATIONS.
WE WILL NOT TURN BACK.
YOU ARE THE PREVIOUS
GENERATION.
I WATCHED YOUR PROTEST ON THE
GROUND IN IRAN AND SOY CRUSHED
BY THE REGIME.
DO YOU THINK IT WILL BE ANY
DIFFERENT THIS TIME?
.
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK THIS IS A TURNING
POINT.
PRECISELY THAT IS THE REASON.
WE SEE GENERATIONAL CHANGE.
A FUNDAMENTAL SHIFT IN THE
NORMS AND VALUES OF THIS
GENERATION.
I WAS BORN IN THE 19 80S.
THOSE WERE PEACEFUL PROTESTS IN
2009, WE STILL HAD HOPE IN
ELECTORAL REFORM AND INTO THE
STRUCTURAL REFORM IN THE AS
LAVA REPUBLIC ARE SLOGAN WAS
VERY CLEAR.
--
WE SEE TODAY, WE'VE SEEN THAT
WOMEN AND WOMEN'S RIGHT IS
TAKING CENTER STAGE IN THIS
PROTEST.
AND MOST OF THE PROTESTERS IN
THE STREET IN FACT BELONG TO
THE GENERATION THAT WAS BORN IN
2000 ONWARD.
A LOT OF TEEN PROTESTERS, WHO
OVER THE PAST THREE WEEKS HAVE
BEEN SHOT IN THE STREET, ARE 16
OR 17 YEAR OLDS.
I THINK THIS IS A VERY CLEAR
AND OBVIOUS CHANGE AND SHIFT IN
THE FUTURE POLITICS OF THE
IRANIAN SOCIETY.
AS WELL AS GENERATIONAL SHIFT
IN THE FUNDAMENTAL NORMS AND
VALUES.
OKAY, SO, LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
THE SIGNIFICANCE OF WHAT
HAPPENED AT SHARIF IN
DIVERSITY.
IT'S A VERY ELITE UNIVERSITY,
AND MANY IRANIANS WHO GET
THROUGH, YOU KNOW, GO TO
HARVARD, GO TO ALL SORTS OF,
YOU KNOW, IMPORTANT HIGH-LEVEL
ACADEMIES AROUND THE WORLD.
BUT ALSO, THE FACT THAT THERE
HAS CRACK DOWN THERE, SO, THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THAT LOCATION,
COUPLED WITH THE FACT THAT --
CAME OUT FROM WHAT SOME PEOPLE
THOUGHT WAS, YOU KNOW, HIS
DEATHBED, TO CONDEMN AND DO IT
AT A MILITARY POLICE ACADEMY.
WHAT IS THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
BOTH OF THOSE ISSUES?
>> YES, I THINK, FIRST OF ALL,
I THINK IT'S UNPRECEDENTED AND
VIOLENT CRACKDOWN ON SURE IF
YOU DIVERSITY OF TECHNOLOGY
CAMPUS IS AN EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AND ALARMING SIGN
THAT THE CURRENT GOVERNMENT,
YOU KNOW, HISTORICALLY,
OBVIOUSLY, THEY HAVE A HISTORY
OF CRACKING DOWN ON THE
UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES.
I THINK SURE IF UNIVERSITY IN
PARTICULAR IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
IT'S ONE OF THE MOST
PRESTIGIOUS UNIVERSITIES IN THE
COUNTRY, AND REPRESENTATIVE OF,
AS YOU MENTIONED, IN THE WORLD,
IT IS A VERY IMPORTANT ACADEMY
INSTITUTION.
WHAT WE SAW IN RESPONSE TO THIS
VIOLENT CRACKDOWN ON STUDENTS
AND PROFESSORS WHO WERE SHOT BY
RUBBER BULLETS, AND THEY WERE
ARRESTED AFTERWARDS, IT IS THAT
THE INTERNATIONAL ACADEMIA IS
ACTUALLY RESPONDING VERY
QUICKLY AND STRONGLY CONDEMNING
THIS CRACKDOWN ON SHARIF
UNIVERSITY CAMPUS.
AND ON THE OTHER HAND, I THINK
THE FACT THAT THEY CHOSE THE
POLICE ACADEMY FOR HIS SPEECH
AFTER THREE WEEKS OF SILENCE,
IT IS A VERY TELLING GESTURE
AGAINST ACADEMIA, AND AGAINST
THE STUDENTS MOVEMENT THAT HAS
BEEN ONE OF THE MAIN AND MAJOR
ENGINES OF CHANGE AND SOCIAL
PROTEST IN THE PAST FOUR
DECADES IN IRAN.
WHAT I SAW YESTERDAY IN HIS
SPEECH WAS A CALL ON THE ARMED
FORCES TO BRUTALLY CRACKDOWN ON
THE PROTESTERS AND PARTICULARLY
ON THE STUDENT MOVEMENT, BUT I
ALSO SEE THAT HE'S CREATING A
VERY CLEAR AND VERY DANGEROUS
BINARY BETWEEN INDEPENDENT
ACADEMICS AND RESEARCHERS AND
SCHOLARS AND STUDENTS.
THE ARMED FORCES AND THE POLICE,
AND BASICALLY PROMOTING POLICE
BRUTALITY AGAINST PROTESTERS.
>> SO, YOU HAVE BEEN, I MEAN,
YOU HAVE THAT EXPERIENCE
YOURSELF THERE, YOU'RE WATCHING
VERY CLOSELY AND SOCIAL MEDIA.
CLEARLY ALMOST ALL OF THE
EVIDENCE THAT WE HAVE OF THIS
UPRISING COMES FROM SOCIAL
MEDIA.
I JUST WANT TO PLAY A FEW
LITTLE CLIPS.
HERE IS ONE WITH WHAT LOOKS
LIKE SCHOOL GIRLS WITH THEIR
BACKS TURNED, SINGING A
WELL-KNOWN SONG THAT'S BECOME
AN ANTHEM.
WILL PLAY A LITTLE CLIP.
THEN WE'LL ASK YOU ABOUT IT.
♪  ♪
>> SO, YOU KNOW, A LITTLE
DIFFICULT TO HEAR, AT THE END
THEIR CLAPPING FOR THEIR FUTURE.
IT IS QUITE BRAVE OF THEM.
THERE IS ANOTHER CLIP THAT WE
HAVE, WE'LL JUST PLAYED AS
WE'RE TALKING, WITH EVEN
YOUNGER GIRLS, MAYBE THE SAME
AGE, BUT THEY'RE GOING AFTER
THE ADMINISTRATOR AT THEIR HIGH
SCHOOL.
CALLING HIM DISHONOURABLE AND,
--
AS THEY SAY IN FARSI.
THIS IS A HUGE AMOUNT OF
COURAGE THAT IS ONGOING BY SUCH
A YOUNG YOUNG GIRLS MOSTLY.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK THIS IS AN RESPONSE TO
YOUR FIRST QUESTION ABOUT THE
GENERATIONAL CHANGE, I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT IN THESE
PARTICULAR REVOLUTIONARY
EPISODE IN IRAN, WHAT WE SEE
TODAY IS BRAVE ACTS OF CIVIL
DISOBEDIENCE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
IN HIGH SCHOOLS AND
UNIVERSITIES, LET'S NOT FORGET
THAT THESE GIRLS, THESE HIGH
SCHOOL GIRLS, THEY CAME OUT
EXACTLY ONE DAY AFTER THE
BRUTAL CRACKDOWN ON THE
UNIVERSITY.
THIS WAS COMPLETELY
SPONTANEOUS.
THESE GIRLS DON'T HAVE A
LEADER.
THESE GIRLS ARE NOT CALLING
UPON A LEADER.
THEY ARE THE LEADERS.
AND THE FACT THAT THEY ARE THE
MAJOR AGENTS OF CHANGE RIGHT
NOW, I THINK TELLS US THAT
THERE IS A SHIFT IN, YOU KNOW,
THE FUTURE POLITICS OF IRAN
TOWARDS A MUCH MORE RADICAL OR
ORDINARY CITIZEN BASED POLITICS
THAT REALLY LINKS THIS TO
TRANSNATIONAL MOVEMENTS ACROSS
THE WORLD.
THOSE LEADERLESS MOVEMENTS THAT,
YOU KNOW, WE ARE WITNESSING AND
HAVE WITNESSED IN THE PAST,
SUCH AS BLACK LIVES MATTER
MOVEMENT IN THE U.S., OR THE
PRO-DEMOCRACY MOVEMENT IN HONG
KONG, OR THE ANTI-EASTERLY
MOVEMENT CHILEAN ECUADOR.
I THINK THESE ARE EXAMPLES OF,
YOU KNOW, EXTREMELY EMPOWERED
AND EMPOWERING CITIZENS OF THE
COUNTRY.
AND THE ISLAMIC REPUBLIC IS
ACTUALLY COMMITTING, THIS IS AN
ACT OF POLITICAL SUICIDE THAT
THE ISLAMIC REPUBLIC IS
COMMITTING AGAINST ITSELF BY
TARGETING THIS GENERATION.
THIS GENERATION IS VERY
DIFFERENT FROM THE 19 80S,
THEIR IMAGINATION IS DIFFERENT,
THEIR ASPIRATIONS ARE VERY
DIFFERENT.
MY GENERATION, THOSE OF US WHO
ACTUALLY WERE BORN AND RAISED
UNDER THE ISLAMIC REPUBLIC
DURING THE EIGHT YEARS OF WAR
AND IN THE POST WAR TIME, WE
COULD NOT IMAGINE A DAY THAT,
YOU KNOW, WOMEN GO TO THE
STREETS AND THEY --
WITH THEIR VEILS.
THIS IS A MAJOR AND RADICAL
SHIFT THAT COMES WITH THE
GENERATIONAL SHIFT IN IRAN.
>> YEAH, BONFIRES WITH THEIR
VEILS, IT IS A REALLY POWERFUL
STATEMENT, IT IS A REALLY
POWERFUL IMAGE.
YOU YOURSELF REBELLED AGAINST
THE HIJAB AND, YOU KNOW, THE
FORCED NATURE.
OF COURSE, I WOULD HAVE TO WEAR
IF I WAS AN IRAN, COVERING IT,
YOU KNOW, WORKING THERE.
IT'S STRICTLY ENFORCED.
SOMETIMES LESS STRICTLY THAN
OTHER TIMES.
WHAT WAS YOUR EXPERIENCE?
>> YEAH, SO, FOR MANY OF US,
CHRISTIANE, WHO WERE BORN AND
RAISED UNDER THE ISLAMIC
REPUBLIC, WE REALLY HAD TO
FIGHT IN THIS INSTITUTIONALIZE
MASSAGING ON SO MANY LEVELS.
IT WAS INTERESTING, YOU KNOW,
IN THE STREETS, FOR MANY
IRANIAN WOMEN THEY HAVE TO
FIGHT THEIR FAMILIES, THEY HAVE
TO FIGHT THERE, YOU KNOW,
SOMETIMES, YOU KNOW, SCHOOL
PRINCIPALS AND LATER ON IN
UNIVERSITY, SOMETIMES THEY
REBEL AGAINST THEMSELVES YEARS
LATER AFTER FOLLOWING THOSE
STRICT AND INTERNALIZING THAT
MISOGYNY.
FOR ME, IT WAS PARTICULARLY
COSTLY AND FICKLE BECAUSE I
RENOUNCE PUBLICLY, I ANNOUNCED
THE HIJAB FOLLOWING THE 2009
UPRISING.
AND, YOU KNOW, I WAS THE TARGET
OF THE HARD-CORE RADICALS, AS
WELL AS OTHER, YOU KNOW, SOME
SO-CALLED OPPOSITION GROUPS
THAT DID NOT PARTICULARLY
WELCOME PRONOUNCING, YOU KNOW,
PUBLICLY THE COMPULSORY HIJAB.
LET ME ALSO CLARIFY THAT WHEN I
SAY MAKING BONFIRES WITH BILL'S,
IT'S REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT
FOR THOSE IN THE WEST TO KNOW
THAT WHAT WE ARE PROTESTING
AGAINST AND IRAN TODAY IS
COMPULSORY HIJAB, THIS IS NOT
ABOUT THE HIJAB, THIS IS NOT
ABOUT ISLAM, THIS IS ABOUT
TAKING OWNERSHIP AND RECLAIMING
OWNERSHIP OVER OUR BODIES, TO
HAVE THE FREE CHOICE OF
CHOOSING HOW WE WANT TO
ADDRESS.
WE DON'T WANT TO BE TOLD BY
THIS STATE OR BY ANYONE ELSE
HOW TO DRESS.
I THINK THESE WOMEN ARE TAKING
A HUGE RISK.
BUT WE HAVE REACHED A POINT
THAT I THINK THERE, YOU KNOW,
THEIR RAGE IS GOING BEYOND
CONTROL.
THIS COLLECTIVE RAGE IS GOING
TO MARK A TURNING POINT IN THE
HISTORY OF WOMEN'S MOVEMENTS
AND IRAN.
WE ARE GONNA KEEP WATCHING IT.
JUST TO REMIND EVERYBODY THE
SLOGAN OF THIS MOVEMENT IS
WOMEN, LIFE, MOVEMENT.
FATEMEH SHAMS, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US.